Mallory who was the first big-name actor
that signed on to yama song we actually
got Malcolm McDowell first because he
had worked with us on kids vs monsters
so he wanted to do another dark dunes
production we were really happy to cast
him as Lord gear his voice was perfect
for it and then once you found out that
he was attached it was probably very
easy then to get other names as well
well with the process after Malcolm
signed on is that we got our two
executive producers Toby fraud and
Heather Henson and once we had their
names attached to the project that's
when we started getting you know will be
wiggle berg and nathan and that's when
all the other talents sort of fell into
place after that it was a course of a
few months to cast everybody and so once
you had him attached then did you go and
actively seek out these two producers or
you shopped it around and we
specifically looked for them oh you did
because I mean proud and Henson those
are the two biggest names and puppets
sure so we definitely we wanted them
specifically any tips to other
filmmakers excuse me any tips to other
producers on when you know certain
people you want attached the approach
because sometimes I know it's a gentle
approach other times it's good to be
aggressive there's like a balance there
definitely is a balance and I think the
thing that at least worked for us was
just our enthusiasm for the project Yama
song is such a unique and completely
different than anything else that's out
there right now and we love it so much
and we were so authentically excited
about it so we were we weren't super
aggressive but we were just overjoyed
with what we had and that really
attracted a lot of people to it right so
it sounds like just the authenticity
this t2 what you love uh-huh and it
showed through definitely were there
times when you were presenting it to
these two producers that you were like
if this doesn't happen like you you felt
that like I need this to happen but you
knew you had to kind of quell yeah we
keep we keep all that pretty hard huh
you